[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez avoir des dobble vous allez
avoir également des unlocks des jeux ou
des escape game en qu'on peut faire
entre amis vous allez avoir aussi
également quelques posters Pokémon qui
qui vont être distribués des gop-up
plusieurs timelines également le jeu
pour nous c'est très important c'est un
peu notre ADN de pouvoir partager des
bons moments en famille entre amis et on
sait que ça sera pas possible hélas pour
pour pas mal de personnes et dans le
besoin on bien sûr avec grand plaisir de
les aider pour passer de bons moments de
famille avec leurs proches
[Musique]
depuis deux ans on a lancé donc la Task
Force RH qui regroupe aujourd'hui 80 à
85 entreprises ce qui représente 150
acteurs RH et nous passons avec un bus à
prêter par la RATP et nous allons
collecter des jouets comme vous le voyez
aujourd'hui le bus est rempli nous
allons les connecter pour ensuite les
distribuer à 5 associations qui sont
partenaires et j'ai donc de mi-spop
l'association Aurore baliski le Secours
Catholique et les Restos du coeur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]